Good morning Hank, it's Monday.
I woke up on Friday around 8 AM in Los Angeles,
the city of palm trees, pleasant weather,
news helicopters, prestigious zip codes, terrible
traffic, and astonishingly sparse mobile internet.
As I drove over to my friend Ransom's house
I heard on the radio there had been an earthquake
and a tsunami in Japan, and I was so wrapped
up in the news that I got lost, and since
my phone didn't work as a mobile atlas anymore,
I had to call Ransom for directions. "I mean,
I see a sign that says Wilshire and I see
a sign that says San Basante and the signs
seem to imply, uh, that there's a perpendicular
rather than parallel relationship between
those two places but what you're seeing on
the map disagrees with that."
I finally made it to his house, we went inside
and read about the earthquake and then somehow
got to talking about his photographs. Ransom
collects photographs taken of and by people
he doesn't know. He has thousands of them
in these plastic slip cases, and he's obsessed
with the stories that these photographs contain,
particularly when you flip them over. This
one, for instance, "Rock Wall near Rose Bowl
Pasadena, California, where Dorothy found
a baby girl on January 24, 1961."
Hank, Ransom used photographs like this one
to make one of the greatest youtube videos
of all time, link in the dooblydoo.
We drove down to the beach then, where this
newscaster was like "This very ocean just
devastated Japan." And then I ran into the
water like a boss, forgetting that I had shoes
on. Then Randy took me over to the Venice
Canals, a few blocks of L.A. that look like
Southern California and Amsterdam had a baby,
and we walked around talking about how weird
it was to stroll these sun-drenched canals
on such a tragic day. But then really, all
human life in lived in close proximity to
tragedy. We saw bird flowers and a park for
ducks and these turtles. Too quiet for the
camera to hear, Ransom said "Wouldn't it be
sad if a child's pool were enough imprison
you?"
Then I had to leave for a wedding, so I participated
in an activity that people in Los Angeles
call "hopping on the freeway" which does not
in any way resemble hopping. As I idled back
toward our hotel, the news on the radio got
worse and worse. And then I put on a suit
and went to the wedding.
The reception was at a beautiful home in Beverley
Hills, and as I drank free champagne and looked
out over the pool, I thought about how, even
though we were kind of in a desert, the water
had been everywhere that day. From the pool
to my champagne glass, from the turtle pond
to the canals to the ocean. I found myself
wishing there were some way for those of us
on one side of an ocean to tell people on
the other side that we were thinking of them,
a way that I could say that, not only to the
people of Japan, but also to Dorothy, who
had found that baby girl in 1961. But images
can travel in a way that our thoughts can
not, and that night I felt sad and frustrated
that technology can never quite bridge the
oceans between us.
Hank, you'll find a link to the Red Cross
disaster relief fund in the dooblydoo. Welcome
back from Haiti, I'll see you on Wednesday.